It's so difficult to explain what I feel now...
...because it was a really difficult day I think for all skaters.
Certainly you could see it.
I try to do my best on the ice.
There were some moments that I'm not satisfied with, but after my performance,...
...I really understand that I fight for every element,...
...I tried to do my best in every second of my program.
And so I was really surprised when I saw the place and so, so happy.
And I really understand that every jump was so important.
Like before the short program, I really didn't think about any places here.
I just thought only about my programs.
But after the short program, when I was first,...
...first I became more nervous because I felt like it's my chance.
And maybe it's better that we had one day between short and free program...
...because I had time to think about all.
Because yes, I became more nervous...
...after the short program when I realized that I really have chances here.